ااااه طبعا هو المسلسل ده كراون دي دوره
جديده يعني كل دوره بتكون عده حلقات
ومستمر
والدوره الاخيره هي عن الراحله دايان امير
الكويت اللي هي اا كانت مكان جلاله الملك
تشارلز لسه امير وويلز
وتوفت في حادث السياره الشهير وبيتناول
هنا همم
القائد على الشخصيات تصادف ان انا طبعا في
سن يعني حاليا انا مؤرخ والصحفيش هذه
الفتره يعني هذه الفتره همم الامير ان شاء
الله خطا فيها ديانا وتزوجوا قبل الحادث
وحتى همم في الفتره اللي هو اصبح فيها
امير ويلز هو كان لسه شاب صغير في نهايه
فانا عشت هذه الفتره
بهذه الاحداث اصلا احداث مختلفه مختلفه
يعني همم مثلا رؤساء الوزراء السابقين
اللي هم كانوا بجلاله الملك الله يرحمها
انت عارف انا رئيس الوزراء يلتقي بالملكه
بعد الظهر يوم الثلاثاء
لها من الوقت الفن
الاول وبعدين يوجد الناقد والنقد توجد
النقايس طبعا الفنان ما حدش بيقول له يعمل
ايه لكن المشكله نحن امام الان اجيال
بتاخذ معلوماتها من التلفزيون من الاعمال
الدراميه مش جاك جيل بتاعنا اللي بياخذ من
الكتب وان الوثائق وبعدين التاريخ
بالمناسبه هو كائن حي التاريخ عمليه
مستمره هناك وثائق بيفرج عنها في المملكه
السعوديه هناك وثائق بيفرج عنها في
بريطانيا في الولايات المتحده مكتبه
الكونجرس مكتبه مجلس العموم كان هذه
الوثائق كل 50 سنه او 60 سنه بيعاد
التغيير وبيعات تصحيح معلومات ما كانش
متاحه وقتها فهو الكائن حيبقى يتحرك مشكله
العمل الدرامي الثابت ان انت هتتفرج عليه
بعد 20 سنه او 30 سنه كما هو والاجيال
بتاخذه على كائن تسجيل له الواقع لحد فهي
معدله حقيقيه عشان كده انا سميتك نزيف